millions of years ago a meteorite made
of vibranium exposition about a
meteorite meteors position exposition
right also the generation a meteorite
made of vibranium struck the continent
of Africa affecting the plant life
around it yeah but just the plant life
of Africa I mean wouldn't a meteorite
big enough to affect an entire continent
trained a lot of things over the world
until a warrior shaman received a vision
from the pen that God is best ooh with
what now led him to the heart shaped up
a plant that granted him superhuman
strength speed and instincts this planet
is basically Jesus Jesus the warrior
became King and the first Black Panther
roll kitties to keep the brainian safe
the wakandans vowed to hide in plain
sight
you know what Condor has the same
problem as Wonder Woman's the mascara
you tell him either before Klaw did his
heist not one asshole stumbled upon
Wakanda by accident in all those years
yeah it's surrounded by mountains and
what looks like a rain forest but there
are still flying things like airplanes
right seas to Grace Jones looking chicks
funny joke but Surrey is soon revealed
as being in on the whole undercover
operation so why would he continue the
subterfuge
even after in Joe who knows he's caught
this man ulysses klaw who looks
remarkably the same here is he willing
26 years did you think that you were the
only spy we sent here to Oakland yeah
totally
to the United States no I'm not that
stupid point is you have been too vague
in your question for my answer to matter
at all yes it's only 33 seconds of logos
but it's all just one logo and that's
excessive the tiny nation of Wakanda is
mourning the death of its mana I know we
need the exposition for the people that
didn't see Captain America Civil War but
T'Challa is seriously using his
incredible technology to watch BBC news
this opening action sequence is just way
too dark I can't even call the movie out
for bad staging or choppy editing
because I literally can't see anything
to ruin my mission I will be crowned
King tomorrow I wish for you to be there
wait Nakia was on an undercover mission
to take down a group of human
traffickers and to charla it all up just
so she could come to the crowning
ceremony I know it's important it but
more important than busting a group of
King human traffickers are yourselves
home
I'd take deploy what I really she
herself has to get back to Wakanda for
the crowning tomorrow but our heroes are
literally turning to all these just now
release prisoners and saying KanCare
yourselves oh there's no further
assistance you or Wakanda can provide
believe it or not this glory shot at a
landscape with herds of animals running
near a body of water is the least over
lion king rip-off this movie has to
offer
I'm not saying something mighta deceased
that came to see me off before the
siblings immediately identify each other
as siblings anywhere else other than the
movies just something works doesn't mean
that it cannot be improved my dick in a
nutshell dude I don't care if it's his
precociously brilliant sister or not
Cherie just flipped off the current
Prince and future king of this country
in front of all these people with no
repercussions and in case you confused
it for London Nebraska
I mean seriously does anyone meet the UK
part of this title card this is the most
London in London shot ever to London
where is this one far present-day Ghana
well what about this one this eventual
reveal is predicated on the fact that
this museum refuses to use any
descriptive cards for their priceless
artifacts so how do they need the guise
of the paramedics there's no way the
room cleared that fast oh cool I guess
claws claw comes with a weapon polishing
setting okay so the water is being
drained ahead of the falls and all these
people are arriving by boat above the
falls so is there a staircase in these
rock faces do they all rappel down will
be definitely yada-yada is how everyone
actually gets to the very specific and
temporary location for the crowning
slash fight the CG on these Swain people
is so bad the maker of weebles has
suited in civil court for copyright
infringement I'm super confused about
one thing how the throne of Wakanda and
the title of Black Panther are seemingly
linked and yet definitely not linked
because he's been black panther for a
bit even before his dad died and now he
has to have his panther purple drank
powers medically removed in order to
fight for the honour of being King upon
which they will reap herbal drank his
ass and get his super powers back but he
wasn't King before now and still had
powers and was out there fighting he was
black panther estado in civil war did
his dad decide to stay King but give up
the panther juice to his son
goddammit I've written seven lines in a
Word document about this and I'm still
angry about it but also now questioning
my sanity and whether or not I'm the
only one asking these questions
oh no one notice that the jabari tribe
was missing from this entire ceremony
before now I mean it makes for a
dramatic entrance but there definitely a
part of Wakanda and this is a pretty
important de marmol look you should make
a spin-off horror series about mbaku and
the clay masks I don't know if it's the
double eyes or the double mouth or the
west-world worthy map carved into his
forehead but this is the most
frightening movie character I've seen in
years
scoffs I tried this on okay a few things
technological advancements should be
overseen by whoever makes them go
smoothly and rapidly what she is doing
second she's 17 going on 18 and almost
no decent english-speaking person would
call her a child 30 you've been up in
the mountains dude you don't get to come
down after I'm guessing decades and
start demanding you chose to leave and
live in seclusion forth and maybe most
simple don't all teenagers scoff a
tradition who could not keep his own
father safe low blow especially since he
and his father were way outside the
borders of Wakanda where they can't
possibly control all variables that got
bombed and dude is making it seem like
the chocolate just refused to do the
Heimlich maneuver on his choking father
lowered it to a hanuman wait who hanuman
feels like a sudden new name we are
giving glory prayers to baku had some
great trash talk before the fight but
what the hell does this have to do with
anything
character is close to death but is able
to come back because of an inspirational
shout from the audience cliche what the
hell is to charles plan here if when
baku doesn't yield his ass is definitely
going over the falls too even though he
was just gored with a super heavy spear
two challahs chest wound isn't bleeding
at all because we don't want to obscure
those beautiful abs right and so begins
the most annoying request of chadwick
boseman career just officially elected
king to chow last two owned agro the
purple heart flower ceremony in order to
receive the black panther powers that he
had prior to this but apparently had to
give up after his dad died until he was
officially elected king or some point is
the half assed this from the get-go damn
this is a MCU movie right so why are the
effects often still lacking they
couldn't afford those wet assholes that
did the jungle book I know to Chama has
security with him and everything but
nobody even looks at the king of Wakanda
as he walks down a busy street let alone
ask for a selfie brought it to Boston
still gray Rhino shadowing my king my
love damn smokey has a lot of
expositional greetings and this movie
does enjoy spending lots of its time gee
whizzing it itself and what are these
question is the entire suit sits within
the teeth of the necklace man I love
this Q style tech introduction of the
gadgets as much as anyone but the use of
vibranium totally bypasses explanation
of how all this was developed like it's
basically this is the greatest tech ever
invented
yeah but vibranium forever in my nights
absorbed the kinetic energy and hold it
in place for redistribution but really
only in this movie you'll see it an
infinity warm but only in the wide shots
for some reason yes we pick back and
forth you probably could have saved a
lot of money by bypassing Lupita Nyong'o
in favor of Willow Smith for this role
I saw a Medicus I know Nokia's a badass
spy and all that but how they can she
tell that all three are Americans just
by looking at them from across the
casino what I'm doing or not doing on
behalf of the US government is none of
your concern
I like martin freeman a lot I even have
a John Watson and a Bilbo Baggins poster
up in my bedroom but could they really
not get an actual American actor to play
the Warren American that's prominently
featured in this movie didn't I keep it
under wraps that the king of a
third-world country runs around and cats
him despite speaking in somewhat hushed
tones this super sensitive conversation
is easily haribol by anyone nearby the
king of Wakanda is here Ross is a
seasoned veteran of the CIA but he
seriously still stalks into his sleeve
when communicating with his team in case
we didn't have enough clues about what
an evil prick claw is he doubles down on
the parade of villainous black SUVs true
you got a mixtape coming out actually
there is one I'll send you the
soundcloud link if you lock don't forget
to catch me on my Institute and check
out my Etsy yes hey how the hell does
useless henchman number four know who a
Koya is even if they're getting set up
it's not like they'd know exactly who be
with T'Challa qualifiers three rounds
directly into the bulletproof suitcase
instead of aiming literally anywhere
else this casino fight is rad punctuated
by this glorious one shot up and back
down then back up again panning action
Bravo movie man good thing Kalam was out
of bullets there look T'Challa would
have totally wasted that bulletproof
suit he's not currently wearing wait
boss sick just right yeah but that's
very important information and it takes
much less time to just say right guys I
know it's a preposterous superhero movie
but seriously this works
the hell is this dudes plant sure the
bullets can't penetrate the car but they
can totally penetrate the obvious of
Khoya on top of the car
Wow I must have missed the part where
this Black Panther movie officially
turned into a Bugs Bunny cartoon no mall
the songs to have crossing while in
custody so that we know he's crazy you
guys went with this one Shepherds
textiles cool outfits it's just a
chocolate really need the secret
communications device I mean I have a
long way mirror in this interrogation
room so I wouldn't they also be able to
hear what they're saying how is this
take their weapons claw helpfully expose
it's this information to Ross even
though he has no incentive to do so
except for getting more screen time hey
I really can't blame Andy Serkis we're
milking it there at least he gets to
show his actual face for once despite
his injuries and taking off the mask to
chawla impressively pulls off a flawless
zoom and enhance cliche even though they
just relentlessly pursued cloth
throughout the entire city of Busan I
guess let just let him go here along
with the people that own whatever weapon
kick to traumas a second ago Nucky but
it's Ross that's dying why the hell
would appoint a say this I give me a
Kimura beat this is Stabler that seemed
fun now yeah I'll just stick my who's
what into his whatchamacallit and
something-something vibranium give you
into us we can save him and so the CIA
people just said okay and let him be
taken back for healing to what they
truly believe is a third world country
this man is a foreign intelligence
operative how do we justify bringing him
into our body this is an excellent point
I haven't let anyone into a condo for
centuries but they have to get Ross back
there or he'll die it's not like they're
inviting some random asshole won't tell
anyone
motherfuckers in the CIA 30 years you'll
find out who is in power and did nothing
if you ask for to be different but the
channels only been King for like two
days and you spent most of that time
chasing claw give him a break man he's
playing on me
I know yo boos done some questionable
but why did you chock I have to kill him
dead
he's already disarmed him right this
entire movie could have been eighty
percent less conflict that Takako just
uses like Golconda neck pinch or
something man clown looks pretty good
for a corpse that's been flown from
South Korea all the way to akanda in a
tiny unrefrigerated prop plane and then
dragged across the Prairie in the middle
of a hot day
don't touch anything my brother will
return soon Wow ever Ross maybe the
first movie character in history told
not to touch anything that actually
doesn't touch anything
there's vibranium on those trains
vibranium all around us I understand the
conflict about wanting to heal Ronson
Wakanda after he technically saved
Matias life but once he was okay they
could totally move him somewhere else
other than the technological hub of the
entire country you can't let your
father's mistakes define who you are
thing my kids will be chanting it
themselves into the mirror their entire
lives but also he can and he should and
he does because he lets his father's
mistakes eventually help define T'Challa
himself as a better King more open to
the world and giving eight his father's
mistakes directly led to who he becomes
and how he defines himself oh nine
reason I don't kill you I of Stannis
because I know who you are is that
really the only reason like why is Erik
even really in trouble he's got a
wakandan tattoo so he's not trespassing
sure he's a little disrespectful but
that's hardly worthy of a death sentence
I found my daddy will pay at the claws
in his chest record scratch the fuck
wouldn't to chacas claws have been part
of his suit and retracted back after the
stabbing why do you check the claws and
leave them in the dead body he literally
said to the other guy tell no one of
this and then I guess followed that up
with but I'm gonna leave these claws
here like a riddle or some yeah I'm
exercising my blood right the challenge
for the metals of King and black panther
okay but can I really do this it was a
whole thing earlier about the challenge
being on a specific day when the other
tribes declined to challenge before
mbaku
can any one of those warriors walk in
and challenge at any time I know we in
the u.s. probably shouldn't be judging
any other country's politics but that
seems like an inefficient system also
let's talk about kill mongers way
unnecessarily complicated plan he stole
the vibranium from the Museum in London
just so he could get to Charlie's
interest in capturing Klaw in Busan but
if claws group killed two chawla Eric
wouldn't have had the chance to
challenge him for the throne and why
does he need all this to happen anyway
if all he's trying to do is get Chris
from get out support in Wakanda he could
have just killed claw ages ago
considering he already knows where Conda
is and all this death just so I could
kill you man and I thought my family
get-togethers were awkward last year's
Thanksgiving got nothing on this
kill manga is at once one of our best
comic book movie villains ever and one
of our stupidest this is just so much
dumb it kind of hurts the brain also I
don't know if there's a way to do this
where it's not obvious but who they
believe for a second that T'Challa is
dead here there's 40 minutes of runtime
left
he's the titular character and there's
magic doohickeys all over the place here
of course he survives this Erik beat
T'Challa and everything but he also just
randomly murdered Ghost Dog during the
fight it was a pretty important figure
in Wakanda doesn't that get him in any
trouble I'm loyal to throne know about
the who sits upon it might be time to
reassess the priorities no burn at all
so thankfully she I guess suspected kill
monger might go all burn the winch on
the purple flower and came here to grab
one she intends to use to give to chawla
back his Panther powers but then after
that that's it right no more flowers no
more Panthers after Jala right we start
this throne room scene upside down as a
very subtle way of reminding the
audience that here in Wakanda things are
currently upside down the new king is a
yes damn it tell me to stop taking all
these sins off dude he's just lying
there probably dead that's entirely
possible given the proximity of the
mountains to the waterfall one of our
fishermen found him at the edge of the
river board ah he brought him to me and
I didn't tell anyone like for however
long it took for kill monger to get red
dirted and purple planted and then go up
and change clothes and then go into the
throne room and order weapons sent to
the war dog spot yeah I didn't see
anyone that whole time I just assumed
you guys would deduce that he was still
alive and up here in the mountains and
come here to retrieve it now you have
amazing I can heal him there
thank you you'll be dead in seconds damn
everyone in this country seems to be
able to diagnose and heal anyone with
impunity well how the herb that gives a
normal human superpowers is now going to
serve double duty as an herb that
flat-out heals mortally wounded dudes
near death he let the fifth of how I
discovered he stopped us from doing what
it's right this is the same realization
Chris and I had just before starting
cinemasins we not help you character
insists they won't do a thing only to
change their mind off screen in a few
minutes of movie time and do that very
thing cliche you know they made it seem
like Shuri ran this entire country's
tech during the whole movie and Baku
even called her out in the first
challenge so how are they able to put
this massive effort of the weapons
distribution together without it
all that challenge
I'm the king now but everyone can see
the childhood right and everyone knows
the challenge rules so why is everyone
doing what kill monger sent they can't
wait for it to charla to walk across the
field
Makati back to this clown this entire
movie has been about kill monger and his
killin boner for T'Challa but now that
he sees he's clearly still alive he
tells what copy to do it
boy I escalated quickly I know what
cobby was pissed at T'Challa for not
killing Klaw but his willingness to kill
what was his best friend until like a
week ago is jari ah cool we're all gonna
stop fighting and patiently wait for the
over CGI'd rhinos to show up and make
this otherwise excellent movie into a
show Donnell rhinos take this movie into
full-on Lord of the Rings mode for the
finale and that's not a good thing first
off when did Sheree have time to make
this American style and how does that
even an option and what does that even
mean it's not what the US only has one
type of AB rhenium powered aircraft in
fact I'm pretty sure we don't have any
laser pause okay I know I've hit the CGI
in this movie hard and it totally
deserves it but this is just egregious
we've literally fallen into a pit of
cliche darkness with a large dose of
rubber neo and a healthy amount of Sam
versus Saint you're better than this
movie you'll want to see us become just
like the people you hate so much
couldn't the China at least mention that
he's had a change of heart that wants to
help the world now isn't that worth a
shot before someone gets killed again
you mean my love oh yeah I remember that
these two are I don't know dating I
guess because this has no bearing on
anything that happens in this movie
until now barely in the ocean
well my assess is that jump from ships
because they know death was better than
bondage so everything went back to
normal after that enormous fight all
those wakandans that died for the super
quick rule of kill monger or just it we
all cool now once up again the king of
Wakanda now making out on a very public
street attracts no interest from the
common folk Bucky
[Music]
it's becoming my club don't get me
everybody dies every memory you see
pretty well it just so happens that your
friend here is only mostly dead it's a
big difference between mostly dead and
all that I chose my people but I don't
want your life who led him to the heart
shaped up
[Music]
I was wondering what would break first
spirit Oh
[Music]
your arms off now it isn't well what's
that then